KEVIN VLK: Hello everyone.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
I'm Kevin Vlk.
And today we have the
director, writer, and producer
of "No Escape," John
and Drew Dowdle.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Hello.
Thanks for having us.
DREW DOWDLE: Good to be here.
Thank you.
KEVIN VLK: So
phenomenal film, guys.
Can you guys just go ahead
and just set it up for us
what the movie is about?
And just kind of go through
just the story a little.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Sure.
You want to do it?
DREW DOWDLE: Sure.
Yeah.
It's about an
American family who
goes to Southeast Asia
for the father's job.
And the day they get there
a violent coup erupts.
And they're caught in the
crossfire between a civil war
on the ground.
And they need to escape
the country not knowing
anyone there or the language.
And that's really it.
KEVIN VLK: What was crazy
I think about the movie,
what was really,
really awesome was
how it's like this
classic action thriller
movie, which has just
been really missing
from today's market.
But you know there's
that scene where
you have Owen Wilson tossing
his daughters over to Lake Bell
on the other side
of the building
and there's that scene.
I remember seeing
the trailer and I
was like, K, that's going
to be an intense scene.
But there's literally
like a dozen of those.
And so can you talk
about the balance
of moving the story
along, but inserting
a lot of those kind
of oh my god moments,
are they going to survive?
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
Yeah, I mean we really
wanted to in this film keep
the audience off balance.
Where over and over
it's something breaks.
One way and you think it's going
to be good, but then it's bad.
And to try to throw
in irregular patterns
to things, where you never
quite know which way it's going.
DREW DOWDLE: Yeah,
and to try to find
as many moments of quiet
tension as we could.
As you've seen it's got
a lot of big set pieces
and a lot of really big
action, but we really
like the idea of really
tense, quiet action as well.
So calibrating that kind of
intensity over a long movie
is kind of tricky
to do sometimes.
KEVIN VLK: No.
For sure.
And there's a ton of that
in the movie, actually.
I think that's what's
great about it.
And you directed "Devil."
And what was great
about that movie
was that it basically took
place right in an elevator.
And that was very, very small.
And this is kind of a
small movie as well.
There's not really
too many set pieces.
You're kind of in the hotel.
And then you're on the
streets and a river.
And so there's a lot
of that, so can you
talk about that in terms
of the scope of it.
And trying to keep it
small and intimate,
but still knowing that
there's this huge event going
on the outside.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Yeah,
well one thing we really love
is playing with subjectivity.
And in "Devil" we
actually did a lot.
Like for every scene
in the elevator,
we focus on one character.
And then see what
they're seeing.
So we're seeing their reactions.
And then sort of what
they're looking at.
In that movie it really
rooted you in every scene
in one character's world.
And in this, we really wanted
to stay with the family
the whole time.
So it's this like big,
catastrophic event told
from a very finite
point of view, where
we're with them the whole time.
And you learn about
things as they learn it.
If they're hearing something
we can't understand,
we don't subtitle the language,
if they can't understand.
We're rooted with them.
And I believe that gives you
a much more visceral and kind
of intense experience.
It puts you more into
the like empathetic state
with your main characters.
DREW DOWDLE: Yeah.
We like the idea
too of in a crisis
just the confusion that ensues
over the first hours or days.
You know thinking about just
like 9/11 here in America.
Like that whole first day is
like no one's cellphone worked,
at least in New York.
You couldn't get
a hold of anyone.
You're really dependent
on the information you
could gather on the streets.
And a lot of that
was misinformation.
And so we like
that subjectivity.
We never cut away to a God's eye
view of the city, or to anyone
back in Washington, DC looking
at the news, or anything.
It's very rooted in
their perspective.
And that was also
very helpful for us,
given that we didn't have a
huge budget to make this movie.
That subjective
perspective really
helped us keep the set
pieces more minimal.
KEVIN VLK: Yeah.
No, I thought that
was incredible.
I actually took note of that.
That was actually one
of my questions was,
with no subtitles.
I love that because
as an audience member,
a lot of people do put
that in, especially
in like TV and stuff.
And you're following along.
But I'm sitting there.
I'm like, oh my god,
what are they saying?
Just listen.
It's really, really crazy.
So that was phenomenal.
And I love what you were talking
about with just keeping it
with the family.
It was very true right?
Like, that was a thing.
You were completely,
always focused on them.
And always moving around,
always with one of them.
It never cut away to another
character, another family,
whatever.
They were always interacting
with Lake Bell, Owen Wilson,
and the girls.
And so I kind of want to talk
about your guys' partnership
that you guys have with working
with each other and the balance
between directing, and
writing, and producing.
And so what that balance has
been for the two of you guys?
And the different styles.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Yeah, well
it's a pretty blurry line.
But you know it sort of breaks
down to- I write and direct,
Drew writes and produces.
It's basically we
talk about everything.
When we're shooting we're
both at the monitors together.
And we're talking about this
isn't working and that isn't.
And often I'll go and
talk to the actors,
and Drew'll you will talk to a
crew, or studio, or anyone else
on set.
And then we'll meet back at
the monitors and keep going.
DREW DOWDLE: The relationship
between director and producers
always a lot of the activity
bleeds from one to the other.
And the fact that
we're brothers,
I think there's even more bleed.
And I think with each
movie we make together,
it becomes a little
bit more and more.
John's very much the director.
I'm very much the producer.
But there's so much of
the producorial elements
that John handles.
And it gets more and more
blurry with every movie I think.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: And Drew
is sort of like a hybrid.
There's not many producers
who would sit through
like every day of editorial.
And frankly not many
producers that like directors
would enjoy being
there everyday.
DREW DOWDLE: Would
let me there everyday.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: It's
like through editorial, it's
like Drew, and me, and
Elliott, our editor,
like everyday we're
like three grumpy dudes.
You're like all right this
doesn't work, yes it does.
Between the three of us,
we cover a lot of ground.
DREW DOWDLE: It's good
we have an odd number.
It breaks a lot of ties.
KEVIN VLK: So, who gets final
cut, or who gets final edit,
final say over stuff.
DREW DOWDLE: We never really
get to that, honestly.
I think we're always able
to convince one another.
Or if there's something
that we disagree on
and we put it up in
front of an audience,
usually it's the audience that
informs us if it's working
or not.
And we put a lot of stock in
those first several screenings.
We have family and
friends, or friends
of friends that are a
little bit more objective
than our personal friends.
So you get a sense in the room.
You don't really see
the movie clearly,
until you see it with
a crowded room I think.
KEVIN VLK: I mean it was
insane last night when
we saw it with a full theater.
And people went crazy for it.
And it blew my
expectations cause
I knew it was going to be
this great action thriller.
I was telling you guys
earlier that it reminded me
of those classic like '80s '90s
movies that was just intense.
But this is more intense
than any action thriller
that I've probably seen.
Like I'm telling you there--
DREW DOWDLE: Thank you.
KEVIN VLK: --are so many
scenes in this for the people
who have not seen it yet.
It is batshit.
Like the person next to me
and I were sitting there.
And the whole time I'm just
like, oh my god, oh my god, oh
my god.
Like you're pulling
back from the scene.
And even though it's
not real, you just
feel completely engulfed in it.
DREW DOWDLE: Thank you.
KEVIN VLK: It's
absolutely intense.
And I kind of want to talk
about the genesis of the story,
just kind of where
this came from.
Cause I knew this a
while to get produced.
Right?
DREW DOWDLE: It did.
KEVIN VLK: It was about
seven, eight years.
And what was the
struggles there and kind
of where'd this idea come?
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Well,
the genesis, my father and I
went to Thailand in 2006.
And like right before we got
there a coup actually happened.
And the generals had
taken over the country
and kicked out the
prime minister.
And so we showed up in
the immediate aftermath.
And there's just a tension.
It was impossible to be there
and not be thinking about that.
There was armed guards
all over the place.
As our car was pulling
into the hotel,
they were researching
it for bombs.
And there's just this
like tension of like,
could this go badly?
And I started thinking, what
if I had little kids with me?
Like how would that play out?
And we had previously
been to Thailand.
We're the two
oldest of six kids.
And on a previous
trip to Thailand
we had our two little sisters
with us, Lindsay and the Beeze.
And so we sort of wrote these
girls after our little sisters.
And they're very similar
in personality and stuff
to our little sisters.
You know, considering we were
like 10 years older than them,
so we always had this
like protective streak.
And we traveled a
bunch as a family too.
So we took a lot of details
from our own personal family
travels.
And I mean, obviously,
it never went this bad.
KEVIN VLK: Thank god.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
Yeah, thank god.
DREW DOWDLE: But I can talk
a little bit about just how
challenging it was to get made.
It was very close to
getting made several times
before this time.
People loved the script.
All the financiers and the
studios would read the script.
And we heard so many times that
they sat down to read 10 pages
and they'd end up reading whole
script at midnight in bed.
And like we kept
getting that comment.
But we'd come in with
our pitch and say we
want to shoot it in Thailand.
And the kids are seven and nine.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: And we
want to cast Owen Wilson, who
is not known for action.
DREW DOWDLE: And we want
Owen Wilson and yes.
I mean there was multiple
levels of risk when
it comes to financing
that these guys are just
wired to mitigate risk.
And they saw a lot
of execution risk.
Will audiences accept
Owen in this movie?
Will the kids be good enough?
Or will their
performances be sub par?
And will the whole movie
really suffer as a result?
Will you be able to
actually get the action
that you have on the page for
this kind of small budget?
Is that even possible?
So there's a lot
of those things.
It was an easy one to say no to.
And the ones that
did say yes, we'd
get all the way down the road.
And then, for one
reason or another,
they'd just yank it
at the last minute.
In the previous iteration, right
before the one that we actually
made it with, Bold Films,
but the previous iteration,
we were actually the night
before flights to Thailand
to go make the movie.
And deals were done
with the actors.
And the locations were all set.
We had been there
to location scout.
And our Thai crew
was waiting for us.
And it imploded the
night before we left.
It was really heartbreaking.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: It was like
right before Thanksgiving.
I remember we weren't supposed
to be there for Thanksgiving.
And then suddenly we're
there for Thanksgiving, super
depressed and broke.
And like ugh.
DREW DOWDLE: Totally broke.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
Totally broke.
DREW DOWDLE: It's like we were
living in a flat in Thailand
and like cashed a big check too.
KEVIN VLK: Oh no.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
It's like suddenly
the next year's worth of income
just evaporated, like ugh.
DREW DOWDLE: And we
had nothing on deck.
We had a couple
loose opportunities,
but it was a really
devastating moment.
I got the call.
And then the call I
had to make to John
was really one I dreaded
more than any other call
I've ever made.
And then I remember
John saying, OK
emotionally, I have to just
back away a little bit.
And just, if we can
rebuild it, great.
But I can't keep doing this.
And I totally understood.
And just kind of
quietly on the sides,
I was carving more
money out of the budget
and going back out
to some financiers.
And trying to put
it back together.
Thankfully Owen Wilson, we
called him right away too,
and he said, guys you find
the money, and I'm there.
You just let me know.
And so he was incredibly cool.
And it's so easy for an actor
to bail on a project that
feels troubled.
And he never did.
He just really liked it.
Over the course of the
next six or eight months
we found a new financier.
They were serious.
And as soon as they locked in,
everything went really well.
And the kids were great.
And all those risks, just one
by one, kind of fell away.
What was a totally cursed
project for so many years
suddenly became this
really blessed project
where the stars just aligned.
KEVIN VLK: What was so
great was the casting.
And that's was what
surprised me so much.
I remember seeing the trailer.
Initially I was
like, Owen Wilson?
Like that's a weird
casting choice, right?
And I see Pierce Brosnan.
I was like I'm into
this, you know.
But then you start
watching more trailers,
you start reading more about
it, and then you see the movie.
And it's crazy because he
really hasn't done anything
like crazy action, since like
"Black Hawk Down" kind of.
And it's amazing from
the first scene with him,
which is him right on
the plane, with him
on the plane with his family.
You buy into it.
I'm like, oh, he's a family guy.
Oh I get that.
Like, he's so playful with
kids and so relatable.
And then you go into him
being an action star.
But you ease into it.
And he slowly kind of
starts finding his way.
He accidentally becomes
like this guy just fighting
for his family.
And what was so crazy is,
I don't have kids or a wife
right now, but I
have a girlfriend.
And I'm like, I'm putting
myself in that place.
It was like I would
actually try to do that.
I would try to fight for that.
And so that's how it was for me.
So can you talk about the
casting of Owen Wilson?
Was there a lot challenges with
that with studios being like,
we don't want him.
We want someone like a
Chris Pratt or Tom Cruise
kind of in this.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Yeah.
I mean it's part of the reason
we did this independently.
For a lot of studios, they
can't really lead trends often.
They have to sort of follow
things most of the time.
We kept getting no, it has
to be, someone we know,
like a Jason Statham
or a Bruce Willis.
That's more the direction
we were getting pushed.
I like them fine.
But for this movie,
we really wanted
somebody who felt
like someone, we
like to joke like, without
a special set of skills.
Somebody who seems like a
friend of yours or like him.
How would he survive this?
Or how would I?
Like not somebody
who I've seen be like
a Navy SEAL or
something like that.
And so we wanted something
that felt very real.
And I remember
when we first cast
Owen, people kept asking like,
are you to give him a crew cut,
make him super butch.
And we're like, no, no.
We want the "Marley and Me"
Owen Wilson in this situation.
And we stuck to that.
People were worried like, will
audiences accept him in this?
We were like the first time you
see him yell at one of his kids
like, just do it!
You see him do that
once, and you're
like OK, I've never seen
Owen do this kind of stuff,
like anything like this.
KEVIN VLK: That was
it in the trailers,
like as soon as you
start seeing them,
like you just buy
into it so quickly.
And he's so good.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
He's so good, Isn't he?
DREW DOWDLE: Yeah, to
your point too, we always
knew it was going to be kind
of a show me the situation.
We had to show material
of it for people
to really-- Because when
you talk about this movie
and what it's about, and the
fact that Owen's the lead,
People are like, OK, let's see.
I remember the first time
we seriously discussed it.
We were actually right
here in this neighborhood.
We were on Lucas road
driving to Skywalker.
And we just thought OK, but
when you see that trailer,
like what effect do you have?
We knew we could do.
We knew he'd be great.
But when you see
that trailer, is it
at that point are you resistant?
Or are you really intrigued?
We kind put ourselves in
the audience's shoes to say,
oh I see that trailer, and
I have to see that movie.
KEVIN VLK: You have to see
when throws a kid off the roof.
It's like, you threw a
kid off the roof, what
happens to that kid?
That was insane and
that scene was insane.
But you also have
some great casting
with Lake Bell, who is just
this wonderful chameleon in how
she plays these goofy
characters, like in "Wet Hot
American Summer."
And then she plays
something so serious.
But she's a very, very
strong female character.
And she really holds her own.
She asks her husband
a lot of times.
But a lot times, she's actually
saving Owen Wilson's character
a lot of times.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Yeah.
KEVIN VLK: Which was phenomenal.
And she's really
protecting her kids.
And she's thinking for
herself because sometimes they
are separated.
That's not a
spoiler or anything.
But they are separated
for some periods of time.
And she's taken the initiative
to do a lot of stuff.
So can you talk
about the development
of her character and not making
her this damsel in distress?
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
Yeah, that's well said.
We kept saying we don't
want a damsel in distress.
It's sort of a two-hander.
It's two parents
protecting their children.
And she's so strong.
One of the great
things about her too
is she makes you like
Owen's character more the.
Fact that he married her
makes him substantial.
If she was like some
blonde hair, blue eyed,
like super actressy, you
wouldn't like him as much.
But there's something
about their chemistry.
And they're funny together.
And you can see at a
glance why they fell
in love in the first place.
They have a similar
sense of humor.
And boy, you know, she
really went for it.
It was fun too.
She was like, in
every movie they're
like, oh not so intense with
the eyes, like cool it down.
She's like it's so nice that
you guys are never saying that.
Just go for it.
Do it.
KEVIN VLK: Yeah, cause
she can be really intense.
DREW DOWDLE: Just her action
shots are so powerful.
In editorial we
had just all these
different options
and each moment
was really hard to decide
because she just gives you
a ton, even in the moments
where she's not speaking.
And were really lucky to
have actors that smart too.
I mean, Owen Wilson's an
Oscar nominated writer.
And Lake Bell is a Spirit
Award nominated writer.
And to have actors
that are talented
with dialogue and with
just a sense of script
is really a blessing for us.
That helped a lot.
KEVIN VLK: And then you
bring back Pierce Brosnan
in this great role.
Where you first meet him and
he's completely against type.
And I love that.
And we were talking
about this before too.
He's just instantly
likable, even
if he's not this like
perfect, suave guy and stuff.
He's very, very
like, oh I buy that.
You know.
And I want to watch more
of Pierce Brosnan doing
that stuff.
So, you could talk a
little bit about him too.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
Yeah, Pierce is amazing.
He's such a good
character actor.
Like he can really
do character stuff.
And he sort of came up
in theater in London
doing that kind of thing.
And then he came to
America and apparently
his v very first audition
was for Remington Steele.
He booked a series and
then it was off from there.
And so everyone thinks of
him as like the handsome guy.
But I mean he can
really do some stuff.
DREW DOWDLE: It is challenging
to unhandsome Pierce Brosnan.
You can't beat it
out of that guy.
We really wanted to go rough
and bearded, and red and ruddy,
and alcoholic looking.
And it's still
like Jesus Christ.
KEVIN VLK: Still gorgeous.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
Still gorgeous.
Yeah.
KEVIN VLK: The bastard.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: It's true.
KEVIN VLK: He cannot
be unappealing.
DREW DOWDLE: It's true.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: It's true.
DREW DOWDLE: It's
funny we were there
shooting for I think six
weeks before Pierce got there.
Or five weeks or so.
But we were towards the
end of the schedule.
Everyone in Thailand,
it took 'em a minute
to know who Owen was.
And they didn't have
any idea who Lake was.
But it took 'em a minute.
But after we'd been
there for a while,
they knew they were
the stars of the movie,
so they had some
attention around town.
But then Pierce got there.
Oh my god.
He showed up at the airport
in Chiang Mai to greet Pierce
and it was like, you'd think it
was the Beatles or something.
He is a full blown international
movie star, no doubt.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
And he's so nice.
Like he would literally take
1,000 photos with people.
And he's like the nicest guy.
DREW DOWDLE: He
will take the time.
We were waiting for
him on set one day
and Thai kindergarten class
had come to set to visit.
And we were waiting.
And we were kind of in a hurry.
And he was signing autographs
for this kindergarten class.
And we're like,
Pierce, we gotta go.
He was like, no.
I'm gonna sign every
one of these autographs.
We're like, OK, you know,
it's for a good reason.
KEVIN VLK: You have
a great James Bond
joke that I won't ruin,
but it's phenomenal.
It's a very subtle
hint, but I love it.
And the theater went
nuts for that as well.
That was great.
But can you talk about
just with the kids.
I mean what was so great about
that was you have this action
thriller with the family.
And the kids are an
important part about it.
And they always have to
pay attention to them.
Like they sometimes
are, you stay here,
and I'll go and stuff like that.
But sometimes they have to leave
the kids like, OK, now you're
in charge of your sister.
You are in charge.
And can you talk a little
bit about just that?
That was so incredible because
you don't see a lot of that
either.
You see these action thrillers
with like Liam Neeson trying
to get his daughter
and stuff like that.
But these are small
kids and they're
throwing them off buildings.
And they're hiding
them in bushes
and underneath
stairwells and stuff.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: I mean
it was important for us
to keep the family
together as a unit.
Really in most movies
like this, step one
is you hide the kids under
a thing and leave 'em there.
And then step two is
you have your movie.
And we really wanted to have
them there the whole time.
It's a two front war
for Owen's character.
He's got this adversity
to deal with in the world.
But then he's also
got to convince
his kids to do what he says.
I mean there's moments as a
parent, like I'm in a rush.
I got to get to work.
My kid won't get in the car.
It's like what do you
do at that moment?
Do you just push 'em down into
the seat and strap 'em in?
And then the neighbors
think you're crazy.
There are those moments.
No.
I mean for real.
And we wanted to capture
that in a bigger setting.
Going into the movie that
was frankly my biggest,
from a directing standpoint,
that was my biggest fear.
It's like if these kids don't
work, the movie doesn't work.
Because there's some
really heavy lifting
they have to do to stay in
the movie that whole time.
They really have to hit
some emotional places.
DREW DOWDLE: A lot of dialogue.
And if they weren't
as good as they were,
we'd end up really
trimming their performances
and editorial just
out of necessity.
And that was a big fear.
Because if they get
cut down, they're
going to feel like props.
They're going to
feel like we're just
using them for an emotional
resonance that's not totally
working.
But if their performances really
work, the whole movie works.
So we knew Owen,
Lake, and Pierce
were going to be amazing.
But the kids it's just a--
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: --crapshoot.
So we approached it
like, let's treat them
just like we treat the stars.
There's moments where
we'd say like, I don't
know what it's like to be nine.
I don't remember that well.
I need you to be the expert.
And what would you
do at this moment?
And a lot of the moments in
the movie that I love the most
are things they just did.
There's a moment
where one of the girls
just turns and hugs her
sister cause she's scared.
And that was her doing it.
That wasn't written.
That wasn't something
we asked her to do.
Like they just knew they
could be themselves and be
real in those moments.
And no one was going to
be like that was wrong.
What are you doing?
You just blew a take.
They had free rein.
Along those lines, we
never set marks for them.
The cinematographer
we asked to like we
never want to set
marks for the kids.
We never want them to have
to stand in a certain light.
Like we want them
to have free rein.
If they want to change
it from take to take,
it's their performance.
KEVIN VLK: Well,
that's a great point
too was just the
real human moments.
When you said the
hug thing, there
was so many natural
moments like that.
And so many moments
where I think
get skimmed over in TV
and film all the time.
And you guys had so
many of those in there.
Where you see like
Kiefer Sutherland in "24"
and people are like when
does he go to the bathroom?
When does he eat?
And you never see that
cause it's boring, right?
Literally, the kids
are like, I'm hungry.
And it was like, we now.
Or I have to use the bathroom.
That was a gut-wrenching moment.
It's like I had to use
the bathroom, right?
It was like, you guys
wrote that in there.
And you spent time on it.
That was like a
two minute scene,
where it's just gut-wrenching.
And you know it's that.
And then there's a
scene between one girl
and I won't ruin it with her
and Owen later in the movie.
But it's really,
really well done
with bringing those kids
into the moments and stuff.
But I want to talk
about the insane
moment of throwing the
kids off the building
because that scene was bananas.
It was so crazy because
you see in the trailers,
but the way that
it unfolds there.
Like you were talking about how
you get your kid in the car,
right?
Owen Wilson, what isn't
really shown too much
in the trailers, what's
shown in the movie
is, he has to convince
his kids to actually agree
to be thrown off a building.
And he does an insane, crazy
job with making that happen.
So can you talk about the
evolution of that scene?
Because that had to be
hard to shoot in general.
DREW DOWDLE: Yeah, it was.
It was our biggest set piece,
obviously, in the entire movie.
And I think we spend a good
four or five days on that alone.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
When writing we
try not to write just
things we know how to do.
And this is one like we wrote.
We're like I don't know how
we're ever going to do this,
but let's find a way.
And it was funny we originally
found some stunt girls, who
actually look like our girls.
One was from Zimbabwe
and hadn't worn shoes
until she was like
10 or something.
DREW DOWDLE: One
was from Australia.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
And they were tough.
DREW DOWDLE: And they
were tough, yeah.
And they were willing
to do anything.
Our plan was to put them on
the wires and throw them.
We came up in the plan
that actually worked.
We were doing a test run.
You want to tell it?
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: I was looking
at my iPad of the test run.
I brought my family
with me and my kids
were like in Thai school
and it was really fun.
And I was watching on my
iPad the stunt being done
and my four-year-old son
like saw it over my shoulder.
And he's like, I
want to do that.
And so Drew and I were
like, let's do that.
Let's bring my son.
We'll throw my son off the roof.
And we'll let the
actresses watch.
And if he doesn't freak out,
maybe they'll want to do it.
And it worked.
So I threw my son off.
It was like a four-story roof.
KEVIN VLK: Oh Jesus.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
He was on a harness,
but it's like up to like
a construction crane.
And so I threw him off
and Drew caught him.
And he got up and he
wanted to go again.
And then all the girls were
like, I want to go next.
DREW DOWDLE: Including
the actresses.
The stunt girls and the
actresses all, and the mothers
were there.
You don't want to talk a
kid actor into a stunt.
You don't even want to put
any pressure whatsoever.
So the idea was if they
really want to do it,
then that's a different story.
And so throwing
Henry, John's kid,
It just was like an
amusement park ride suddenly.
And they were all like climbing
over each other to do it next.
And this was just a rehearsal.
She got to go twice.
I only got to go once.
It became like that.
KEVIN VLK: We got so much money.
Stop.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: And we
had originally planned it
that they'd be like sort
of face down, so that we
could swap a stunt kid in.
But once it was the real
kids, then we're like,
let's flip them, so we can see.
But then it's like
now we're throwing
'em off a four-story
building backwards.
And these guys are like
letting the rope out
to a point that
they're free falling.
Like you can tell in
one of those shots,
her torso is below her feet.
Like her feet are up
and it's her torso
that's connected to the road.
So she's free falling.
And they were so brave.
And that was one of things we
always talked to them about.
We have a million
ways of movie magic.
If there's ever something
your don't feel cool
with it's easy for us to
do something different.
And they got that and knew that.
And there was moments
you wouldn't even
guess that like, I don't
feel comfortable being
near a moped when it tips over.
Or things like that, where it's
like, OK, we got it covered.
And so you know, but they
had a good time with it.
But it was gnarly.
We hate using green
screens and CGI,
so we tried to do
everything practically.
KEVIN VLK: And it showed.
It completely showed.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Thank you.
I've
KEVIN VLK: Seen a lot of car
chases and a lot of motorcycle
chases.
And like, "Mission:
Impossible 5"
has this insane, awesome
just motorcycle chase scene.
I'm not sure if
you guys seen it.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
Yeah, it's awesome.
KEVIN VLK: And your
moped scene of them
going through the
crowd at a mile an hour
is way more intense than
that scene from "Mission:
Impossible."
DREW DOWDLE: Thank you.
KEVIN VLK: It had me way
more on the edge of my seat.
It was just a completely
different kind of feeling.
Can you just talk about the
evolution of that cause that
takes a lot of control I think.
So it's an action
thriller, it's like,
oh we have to do this car
chase scene or this thing
through the back alley.
It was like, no, he's got two
kids and a wife on this moped.
He can't do that.
You Top speed's
five miles per hour.
DREW DOWDLE: Yeah.
We always ask ourselves, how
do we do the slow speed chase?
How do we make the really
intense slow speed action?
That one really
worked I thought.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
Yeah, we always about
like, how do you do
the micro-climax?
Like so many films end in this
bombastic you're on a thing
and people are jumping off.
And things are exploding.
And we're like what's the
smallest, like quietest,
like what's the micro-climax
version of this?
And so we always try to think of
this movie really in some ways
like it starts sort of big
and then it goes smaller
and smaller until the end.
And we really like that it feels
more and more intense as you
go, if you're tightening it.
DREW DOWDLE: Yeah,
we like that scene
too in that there's
a moment where,
you have kind of a rabid mob.
This kind of mob
violence mentality.
And then you have a moment with
one individual within that mob.
And he chooses to
not do what you
think he's going to do
because for a moment
he's an individual.
He's not part of
this larger group.
And that felt like a really
nice moment to do that.
KEVIN VLK: Yeah.
And we'll take some
audience questions,
if you guys want to pop
in there and ask anything.
But while they're
getting up there,
can we talk a little bit about
were there any scenes that you
guys wanted to get in
there that you couldn't?
You had to cut for time?
Or just was this pretty
tight knit once you
got into the shooting stages?
DREW DOWDLE: Pretty close, yeah.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Pretty close.
We barely trimmed anything.
There was a scene or two of
Pierce that were so good.
We had a great scene
of him in the hotel
that once we tested
it, we're like OK
we're spending too
long in the hotel.
So we trimmed out a couple
minutes of the hotel
just to get into it.
But there was a great
moment with Pierce
and a woman on the elevator.
He's so funny.
We like to joke that like
Pierce was playing the Owen role
and Owen was playing
the Pierce role.
KEVIN VLK: That's exactly what
I said to my friend last night
was that the roles are
completely switched
and I think that's what
I love the most about it.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Thank you.
KEVIN VLK: That switch
there was really good--
DREW DOWDLE: Thank you.
KEVIN VLK: --you had
that eye on that.
DREW DOWDLE: Really everything
we trimmed from the first cut
to the final cut was pre-riot.
In that kind of early part
of the movie in the hotel.
We realized we spent a
little too much time there.
There's some things that
weren't totally necessary.
The one casualty
that we really regret
was the Pierce and
the elevator scene.
But it was connected
to two other scenes.
And then we could
remove like four minutes
if we got rid of it.
So it became based
on a time thing.
But from the riot to the end,
it changed very, very little,
honestly.
Just really turning screws
more than it was anything.
Scalpel work, not really
any jackhammer work.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
Yeah, and sort of
shaping some of those scenes.
There's a couple
scenes where we just
wanted a little more
breath in the middle.
DREW DOWDLE: It's amazing that
we sold it to the Weinstein
company, and even from
the sale to the finish,
it was almost exactly the same.
It was just really,
really minor tweaks.
And you never know
how that's going
to go with any distributor once
you have a distributor on board
sometimes.
You sign the deal before
you have any idea what
the creative is going to be.
And that's always scary.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Harvey
Weinstein bought it.
He hadn't even seen
the whole movie.
He'd seen like 10 minutes of
it on a laptop and was like,
I'm buying it.
And so then Drew--
DREW DOWDLE: I flew to
France with the DVD,
like OK, I hope he likes
the other 90 minutes.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Yeah,
cause it could go anyway.
You know it could
be like, great.
You know, now that
I own the movie,
let's get rid of those kids.
And let's--
DREW DOWDLE: PG-13
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: --put
some dance numbers in.
You just never know
how it's gonna go.
And thankfully.
KEVIN VLK: A song by
Pierce, that would be great.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: It's
like and you do that.
We sit there and do
that to ourselves.
Like what if he?
DREW DOWDLE: What's he
gonna want to do it now?
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Yeah,
what's gonna happen?
KEVIN VLK: And it's Harvey,
so we got to make him happy.
DREW DOWDLE: There's that.
AUDIENCE: I was curious,
you've had a few movies, now.
What was the experience
filming in Thailand
compared to other locations?
DREW DOWDLE: It was great.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Amazing.
The Thai crews are incredible.
Like it was I would say my
favorite filmmaking experience
ever.
DREW DOWDLE: For sure.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
And we didn't want
to show up as like a big
army of Americans showing up.
We wanted to become like
a part of the Thai crew.
And so we brought very
few people with us.
It was almost exclusively Thai.
And in some departments
we might have one.
We had a guy from Canada,
a guy from France,
and maybe an
Australian, and a Brit.
DREW DOWDLE: And an
American costume designer.
We had less than 10.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
Everyone else was Thai.
And it was so fun.
DREW DOWDLE: And they felt
very creatively connected
to the movie.
A lot of times when
you shoot, whether it
be in LA, or Toronto, or
anywhere, a lot of the crew--
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Louisiana.
DREW DOWDLE: --or Louisiana.
They're there to do a good
job, but they don't truly
care how it turns out.
They're there to
collect a paycheck.
And they're not going to
intentionally do a bad job.
But they are not
emotionally invested.
And we felt like this
Thai crew, there's
so much pride in that
country, and the fact
that we're shooting there.
They wanted to make sure
this film was great.
Most places departments
don't really help each other.
And usually it's union rules.
A grip can't help the art
department carry their stuff
out because there's these
lines between departments.
And in Thailand
none of those lines
exist and everyone's
helping each other.
It was a really
cooperative effort.
And that was very different.
It felt like being
in film school again,
but like having 100
people on your crew
versus like two people.
Everyone's helping each other.
And it was really great.
Wonderful experience.
AUDIENCE: So I was
wondering about you
guys have a lot of experience
in your previous films
with horror.
But this is kind of horror in
a very, very relatable sense,
like real world absolutely
terrified this could happen.
Could you talk
about some of things
that you brought from your
previous films that maybe were
a little more sci-fi-ish
to this kind of real world,
grounded in reality, experience.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
That's interesting.
We actually started before.
We did a film called,
"The Dry Spell,"
which was a comedy, which
is where we started.
And then we started into horror.
And then people got
to know us from that.
But both of those
things are you're
building an anticipation.
And then trying to pay it
off in an unexpected way.
And so comedy works sort
of along that paradigm
and so does horror.
And this being a
thriller, we do a lot
of that in this, where
we try to create suspense
towards something happening.
And then something
happens you don't expect.
And now we have to figure
out a new thing to do.
DREW DOWDLE: Yeah, I mean
our previous three movies
have a similar through line.
In that there's characters,
it's kind of a regular day,
or maybe they're doing something
irregular, but it's a day.
And something happens.
And then chaos ensues.
And they need to try to survive.
And so "Quarantine" and "Devil"
and "As Above, So Below"
all had that kind of structure.
We like to joke sometimes
that our characters never
change clothes in our movies.
It's always in one day.
This time they changed once.
So we threw our casting
designer a bone on this one.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
One change of clothes.
DREW DOWDLE: Yeah,
one change of clothes.
But for whatever reason, we love
that kind of incidental chaos
or crisis kind of movie.
KEVIN VLK: So there
were a few things
that were kind of hit
points all the way through.
One was definitely,
stay 10 steps ahead.
That was pushed
through a few times.
But the thing was the
little girl always asking
for the story of
how she was born.
So can you talk about
where that came from.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: That
actually came from my first son
when my son Henry was born.
It's like maybe over the course
of your life you see like one
or two things that
are truly miraculous.
And for me, I know it sounds
cliche, the birth of my son
was miraculous.
And I don't mean it like that.
He got caught in, not
to get too graphic,
he got caught in my
wife's birth canal.
And all of a sudden,
alarms were going off
and they rushed in
all these doctors.
And they were going to do
an emergency c-section.
And the doula who was there
told my wife talk to him.
Tell him to move through it.
Or they're going to have to
pull him out in an emergency.
And so my wife started
yelling to him to,
like seriously,
through the birth.
And you could see in the
machines his heart rate was
crashing because he was stuck.
And she was talking to him.
And then you can see on the
monitors like objectively,
this wasn't in my head.
You could see objectively
he was reacting
to her asking him what to do.
And it was this moment of,
it's probably the last time
he ever listened to her.
But you could see he
was at that moment.
And it was truly miraculous.
DREW DOWDLE: We always
loved that idea,
like that idea that
[INAUDIBLE] said that day too.
I wasn't there obviously.
But he told me that he knows
your voice, even pre-birth,
he knows this one voice.
And that was an idea that
really stuck with us.
KEVIN VLK: Well, I love
that where it's at cause
the girl asks several
times during the movie
to hear the story.
And he's like, not now, not now.
And you wait.
And the audience wants
to know it too, right?
And I always thought.
By the end of the movie,
I kind of forgot about it.
But then like--
DREW DOWDLE: Good.
Perfect.
KEVIN VLK: --I did.
But then when it got to
the end all of a sudden,
I was like, oh my gosh, yeah.
And then they tell the story.
And it's such a great tie
back to the movie cause
it seems like she's a fighter.
And that's what this
whole thing was.
Like this family who fights
their way through and doesn't
give up.
So that was just amazing.
DREW DOWDLE: Thank you.
Glad you liked it.
KEVIN VLK: Kind of one
of the last points.
Yeah.
What was the hardest thing to
get right in the entire movie
just throughout the process of
either writing or shooting it?
And also what was your
most proudest moment
on the film that came out
that worked out perfectly?
DREW DOWDLE: Oh, good question.
Oh,
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE:
That's a toughie.
I'd say there's a
scene near the end
where, I don't want
to give too much away.
Sort of the last
clinic, there's a scene
with the oldest daughter and
Owen Wilson near the end.
And it's a visceral scene.
It packs a pretty big punch.
And that was frankly the
scene I was the scared-- going
into the movie, I was like,
OK, if this isn't calibrated
perfectly, it's
not to work at all
and people are
going to reject it.
And
KEVIN VLK: I was also
shocked that the studio let
that stay in, by the way.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: I know.
KEVIN VLK: I was shocked cause
I've never seen that before.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: I know.
DREW DOWDLE: Well,
If you notice,
there's literally no
way to take it out.
Sometimes we design those more
challenging scenes to be like
you cannot get around them.
KEVIN VLK: Against a wall and
we have no money for reshoots.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: If
you buy this movie.
DREW DOWDLE: You can't go from
the scene before to the scene
after.
It wouldn't make any sense.
So yeah.
That's kind of our design.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Throwing
the kids off the roof,
you assume when you see
the trailer, like oh,
that's going to be the
climax of the movie.
But that happens like
halfway or a third of the way
into the movie.
Like that's pretty early.
And then when people see that
in their heads, I think they go,
OK, well, it's only
downhill from here.
But no, it keeps going.
And so that was for us sort
of the natural conclusion.
But it's such an emotional
scene for both the girl
and for the father.
And it's gnarly.
I would say that was
the most challenging.
That's maybe the
scene I spent the most
time obsessing over and
trying to figure out
exactly how to get it right.
DREW DOWDLE: In editorial too.
It was exactly what length.
And that one we spent probably
the most time on I would say.
JOHN ERICK DOWDLE: Yeah.
Yeah.
Because that can't
go on too long or--
DREW DOWDLE: --or be too short.
KEVIN VLK: Or be too short.
DREW DOWDLE: It's doing
the right balance.
I'd say the one I'm
most proud of is going
to be kind of a strange choice.
Because it's not
any of the action.
It's kind of before
the action happens.
But there's a scene in the hotel
bathroom between Lake and Owen
that I always loved on the page.
And I was always like, OK,
hopefully this connects
and the performances are great.
And hopefully the
audience likes it.
Because it's kind of
an emotional couple
scene, where she's trying
to suffer in silence.
And he catches her and he
wants to make sure she's OK
but you realize
what he really wants
is her to tell him that it's OK.
And she won't do that for him.
And we got more comments on
that scene from people like,
oh I've had that
moment with my wife.
Or I've had that
moment with my husband.
And I don't know I'm
really proud of that moment
because I feel like
the performances are
just spectacular and
it really connected.
KEVIN VLK: Yeah.
That's really the movie.
It's real and it's relatable.
And you watch it.
And you're like, I hope
that I would act like that
if I were to be put in that
situation with my kids,
or wife, or husband.
It's phenomenal.
So.
DREW DOWDLE: Yeah
KEVIN VLK: Thank you
guys for being here.
DREW DOWDLE: Thank
you very much Google.
It's nice to be here.
KEVIN VLK: Thanks
[MUSIC PLAYING]